good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is the Ingram angle from Washington
tonight we have a jamack show including
an exclusive interview with the parents
of an 11-year-old who say that their
daughter was forced to share a bed with
a biological male while on an overnight
school trip isn't that great plus we're
going to examine the left's two-tier
justice system how violent BLM riers are
treated compared to the January 6
protesters rers but first oh this is one
of my favorites poisoned Ivy that's the
focus of tonight's
angle at America's most elite
universities life on campus for Jewish
students feels like this I was forced to
leave my study group for my doctoral
exams halfway through the semester
because my group members told me that
the people at the Nova Music Festival
deserved to die being a Jew at NYU has
meant being physically assaulted in
nyu's library by a fellow student while
I was wearing an American Israeli flag
and having my attacker still roam freely
throughout the campus while classes were
going on and a mob of 200 people many of
whom not only were not law students were
not Harvard
Affiliates got into our building marched
down the Halls chanting these phrases
Jews took off their
keot and I I watched someone hide under
a desk now it took a lot of guts for
these students to speak out but one by
one they did speak on Capitol Hill today
regarding the rising anti-Semitism at
our nation's colleges and universities
since shortly after the October 7th
Hamas Massacre Americans have seen what
some of us have known for many many
years that our institutions of Higher
Learning have become institutions of
liars earning big money for doing
nothing where are all those diversity
Deans when rallies justifying the
slaughter of innocent Jews were held or
do only leftwing Muslims transgenders
BLM types and I don't know maybe illegal
immigrants qualify well we know the
answer it's yes the lawyers who prepare
the ivy league presidents for their
testimony today must have told them that
when they're asked about anti-Semitism
pivot quickly to
islamophobia during these past months
the world our nation and our campuses
have also seen a rise of incidents of
islamophobia we are seeing a rise in our
society and harassment intimidation and
threats toward individuals based on
their identity as Muslim Palestinian or
Arab we have launched an MIT wide effort
called standing together against hate in
addition to fighting anti-Semitism it
will address islamophobia also on the
rise now this is completely disingenuous
do you recall any
huge rallies on any of those campuses
urging the annihilation of Muslims mobs
of Muslim haters roaming about campus
terrifying International students from
the mid
East has there been any large Gathering
uh you know uh uh in support of the
slaughter of Muslims or the elimination
of Arab State on or near your campus
that you're aware of since October 7
Congressman not that I'm aware of there
have so you would agree then it would be
immoral or dishonest to treat the who as
equivalent problems on campus meaning
anti-Semitism and islamophobia
Congressman I I abhor all acts of
hate that's totally rehearsed right down
to the use of the word
abhor now of course this all begs the
question what happened then when Jewish
students brought their genuine concerns
to college
administrators day after day the MIT
Administration has failed to enforce its
own rules on anti-semitic actors such as
the Interfaith chaplain intimidating
Jewish students Dei staff publicly
declaring that Israel has no right to
exist faculty dismissing student
concerns for their safety by telling
them that if they are scared they should
just go back to
Israel wow fair-minded Americans should
all be grateful to speaker Mike Johnson
Congressman Steve scales and
congresswoman Elise stonic for bringing
these students to Washington and
convening this hearing and not
surprisingly given the jam they're in
college presidents claim that their
supposed respect for free expression is
what kind of affected or constrained
their response to some of these Pro
Hamas
rallies the free exchange of ideas is
the foundation upon which Harvard is
built and safety and well-being are the
prerequisites for engagement in our
community it is crucial that ideas are
exchanged and diverse viewpoints are
debated those who want us to shut down
protest language are in effect arguing
for a speech code problematic speech
needs to be countered with other speech
and with education and we are doing
that did they all have the same speech
writer it all sounded very similar now
since when have these schools been known
for respecting viewpoints other than
those that are fiercely
leftwing now imagine this imagine let's
just someone you know I think pretty you
know sensible Ronda santis a Harvard
grad
what if he came to speak on campus in an
open Forum in
Cambridge I mean an open Forum not just
Invitation Only You Know scripted
question how would it all go down but we
don't have to imagine how things would
go down we know what routinely happens
on campus Stanford students shouted down
judge Kyle Duncan when he visited the
university in March later in March
protesters at Virginia Commonwealth
University yelled at pro-life activist
Christian Hawkins until it escalated
into a fight and police asked her to
leave the room and in April at San
Francisco State University Riley Gaines
was met by an onslaught of trans
activists she was forced to flee the
building and remember that survey that
was conducted last year the political
views of college professors demonstrates
how Conformity of thought is policed in
hiring on campus 50% of professors
identified as liberal 177% as moderate
and just 26% as
conservative now the self-censorship
that goes on at exam time whenever a
paper is assigned or a when a student
maybe is called on in class we're never
going to really know how pervasive it is
but from what I've heard repeatedly from
the Sons and Daughters of friends of
mine who are in school or just recent
grads they say they say things like this
well Laura I just keep my head down then
I write what I think the professors want
to
read that's how they get in
and now these University presidents want
to just throw up their hands and say oh
we're not for speech codes they have
always been for speech codes come on man
to quote Joe Biden now the truth is
there is an active anti-semitic Wing to
the Democrat Party and the Biden team
knows that if the anti-semitic youth
vote doesn't turn out he could be in
major trouble that's why the colleg have
resorted to this Twisted dance of moral
relativism when it comes to the toxic
forces that are bubbling up on campus
and for their part Hill Democrats have
kind of also backed themselves into a
corner and the best they can do is try
to blame Republicans while my colleagues
claim to be committed to combating
discrimination on campus they're also
contradictory and simultaneously stoking
culture Ro culture wars that can be
divisive and discriminatory I hope my
Republican colleagues will denounce the
culture wars that have distracted us
from protecting many vulnerable
students I guess he's talking about
biological men who compete against women
in field hockey or in swimming those are
the vulnerable students have you seen
them please this is more bad acting
there is zero empathy for the Jewish
students who've been traumatized here
and they only started pretending to care
when the donors noticed big donors like
Bill Amman who's been flaming them on x
the sickening reality is this if you
pair your anti-Semitism with
anti-americanism you'll essentially get
a free pass from the top leadership of
elite American colleges and universities
your views are fashionable Cutting Edge
and
protected when these students tell you
that life on campus is unsafe and that
there's a double standard where only
certain people are protected believe
them when the Hamas news dies down and
the cameras pull back this festering
anti-americanism and anti-Semitism will
still be there so now it's up to donors
and alumni to put their money where
their principles are and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else